do you see nope i did
let's see let's hear it i did not like
it um
but
uh
i feel bad saying it but you know what i
like that it was a bit let's be honest a
big movie that was like a non-marvel
entity i didn't think all the ideas
connected
i thought it was a little bit
uh hard to track somebody i thought
there was some brilliant ideas in there
i'm like pretty pretentious when it
comes to movies so but like oh really
with the film school yeah i did a bunch
of them actually bad ones but i did go
all right so you're like
you're kurosawa fan all that kind of
stuff you know i haven't even seen a
curacao all right but you know what it
is
yeah yeah right right um i like well i
don't want to spoil it though can i
spoil yeah it's been awful
i like
that you couldn't look at the alien ship
or that would mean it would come after
you i thought that was a cool detail
okay i like that the alien was alive
i thought that was a good detail and i
thought that the fact that they were
trying to film it
like to save the farm was cool but
everything else i thought was like there
was like too many story lines going on
in it at the same time like there was
the
the monkey side and then there was the
uh
the uh
what'd you think about the monkey stuff
it was really effectively shot like he's
a brilliant filmmaker like he can really
scare the [ __ ] out of you but did you
tell me that was just a random thing
it all felt a bit random to me okay it
wasn't
are you even allowed to say yeah well
yeah because i i i can say i wanna i'll
just tell you
what it is
um so that i don't feel like i'm feeling
uncomfortable about it yeah okay so i'll
just tell you what it is i know i know
what it means what does it mean well
because he's making the same mistake
that they made with the monkey where
like show business things think they can
control these things but that's part of
that yes that's part of what it means
yeah yeah
wow okay that's actually pretty good
nerd
so i went to the premiere
i'm just being honest and i've never i i
i've always thought to myself i would
never try to explain this or even talk
about what i'm but i want to try all
right but i don't want to get into
specifics of it all right so basically
you know um i went to the premiere and
i'd never been invited to a jordan
premiere because i know him
and he specifically called me and he
goes i really need you to be there
because i want to i want you to see
something
that i did for us or
us meaning mad tv
people so i go okay so i went to the
premiere
and i don't know if you remember in
steven union's office there was a mad
magazine on the wall do you remember
that part i don't remember the magazine
but i remember the it was yeah but it
was a there was it was mad it was a mad
magazine with the monkey on it right so
when jordan was on matt tv did you know
that he was on mad tv i did okay um you
know
he
the last month of his contract
on mad he was about to leave the show
and snl called and said we need you this
weekend to play barack obama but i know
you have a couple more weeks on your
contract can you if will matt let you
out and then we'll make you a serious
regular on snl
mad tv refuse to let him go
all right and he lost the show
okay
he also felt like mad tv in many ways
was exploitation
all right so he goes
that scene in the movie of nope was shot
at the mad tv studios where we shot matt
tv
yeah
no uh hollywood center studios right and
he goes
he was the monkey
right and um it was his expression of
how he felt
the exploitation that he felt on that
show and he wanted to put that you know
and obviously it's related to the alien
all that stuff right but it was a
personal thing that he wanted to express
in the movie right and i found that to
be um really cool
you know that he was able to
you know um
just put that in the movie you know what
i mean and for us
you know and um are you the little
i don't want to talk about that part
you are
no what what did you say he
anyway once your movie come out the show
come out yeah august 33
yeah why am i trashing other things
right when our thing comes out i'm like
yeah no you're not trashing i want to
know your opinion because i've been i've
been i've been asking other people about
their opinion about that movie right
because you know i
i'll just tell you when i watched it
kalai and i went to the premiere i was
sitting next to ike baron holt who was
on mattv2 and we've known jordan for 20
over 20 years right
and
i'm proud of him right
and to see him do this movie and we're
sitting there and for him to put that in
the movie for you for you know people
that were a part of mad and just to see
his growth i was just pr proud of him
and i just thought it was a great move i
i came out going wow that was amazing
but i'm hearing other people's opinion
about it and i'm just open to it that's
all right i think you're [ __ ] wrong
very well could be yeah yeah but uh you
know
and you know obviously you know because
this is
i would just say something about this
guy right
check this out right two black leads a
korean lead and a mexican lead in the
movie right filipino too what filipino
who brandon brandon he's filipino he's
half he's
half hispanic as well yeah so he's yeah
he's he's a lead as well right so it's
four minorities as a lead the white guy
doesn't watch the movie
that was the billboard
check out the quick show chat and check
out the
it's nuts my list
i've been watching ghost adventures on
troop tv oh cool what is it ghost of
this ghost adventure yeah yeah yeah yeah
but anyway so when is it so comes out
august what
23rd 23rd everyone honestly
listening to this podcast right now all
right
if you're a real tiger belly fan
and if you're a bobby lee fan right
please support my two